[Music]
let's go to logan in louisville kentucky
what's up logan how we doing brother
uh how you doing can you hear me yes sir
we can how's how's it going
uh how's it going it's going pretty good
uh hey guys i have a little bit of a
weird one for you guys so i'm 19 and uh
my friend's also 19 and
i started listening to dave ramsey about
a year ago and since then uh i i went in
and i saw work at two jobs i work
at a kentucky truck plan i work at ford
and then i also just work a little side
job and we live in a van both of us and
we both work two jobs we've saved up
about twenty thousand dollars over the
course of like this year doing this and
we're just trying to like i'm really
concerned about my future i don't want
to go into debt so like i don't have any
debt in either one of us and we just
want to know where do we put this money
do we put in roth iras do we put this in
state like uh maxing out by 401k at work
where do i put this money
so i'll let george into that but let me
is this a romantic interest or is this
just you and like like a roommate no
this is yeah no this is like a friend
yeah this is me and a friend of my
roommate okay so i would first say don't
speak in terms of we when it comes to
y'all's money
okay just yeah y'all aren't doing y'all
aren't building wealth together you
aren't saving money together this your
right your van mate will have money and
you'll have money so this is your
individual money okay don't don't
ghostbusters one man don't cross the
streams here okay
okay so
you said there's a side business are you
talking about twenty thousand dollars is
from the side business that you guys do
together
no no no so basically now we've just
we've always just said that the money is
just like we've always just put the
money together there is no side business
it's just two jobs why are you putting
the money together
well just because like
honestly i don't know we've just we've
just been friends for so long since you
know real real young and this has just
been i'm good friends with john but we
don't put our money together it's like
bill and ted's one and two like we're
gonna get married together and yeah
again i got great great friends that
i've had my whole life that's awesome um
you guys are scrappy 19 year olds
sharing a van you got no expenses again
not how i would do it but high five to
you man um
but yeah when it comes to sharing money
one of you is going to meet somebody one
of you is going to get another job and
want to move out and untangling that's
going to be chaos you're going to lose a
friend over this that's right and i
don't want that for you so you you've
been listening to the show for a year so
you you know the baby steps so do you
have any debt currently either of you no
no no yeah and do you have any emergency
savings do you have a fully funded
emergency fund
well i mean twenty thousand twenty
thousand dollars we have and i'm
guessing okay so you personally how much
money do you have that's where this gets
real confusing right because you're
saying i don't personally have 20 we
have 20. how much of that is yours
a lot we would just cut out i'd say 10.
i would literally just cut it so i'm
guessing 10 000 is three to six months
of expenses for you or more
oh yeah way more oh yeah okay and yeah
at that point you'd be at baby step four
where you can begin investing the bigger
question here is what is your long-term
future what do you i mean do you want to
be in a van for the next five years
well not maybe not like i mean yeah
probably honestly yeah five years does
doesn't sound bad maybe not 10. i
wouldn't like to push it like past that
but yeah i just i want to like be able
to have a big you know like
dave's always talking about you know
having buying or you know having like a
you know a wealth building tool and you
know your income is your biggest wealth
building tool and you just got to free
up everything so i thought well what was
the best way you know gazelle intensity
what was the best way to like free up
all my expenses okay just live in a van
and then get somebody else in here and
then if we're both doing it and you know
we're both going hard at two different
jobs i don't know
like we're pretty selfless people as far
as like each other but i can definitely
see how that would like be a problem
like like you know the money situation
but yeah in my head it's always been
i just want you to have a vision for
your future and get a great job that you
love and a career that you can sink your
teeth into uh aside from the van yeah
and
man you are a scrappy 19 year old
brother i want to high five you
i'm i'm
further down the road than you are and i
want to also pass along the importance
of a good night's sleep
of a shower
of some stability
and so this might be a six-month plan
this might be a nine-month plan
get a one-bedroom apartment a cheap
one-bedroom apartment that you can begin
to have some stability invite some
friends over and build a future